smoke is [ __ ] cool thank you so much
I'm very very excited to be here this
afternoon honestly to be very blunt I'm
looking forward to getting into this
part very quickly because I this is the
first time I'm speaking in Bucharest and
I don't want to miss the opportunity to
answer your one-on-one questions we
obviously lived in a 2017-2018 world
where a lot of this content is stuff
that you can find online but our
opportunity to engage with each other
and allow me to answer the questions one
on one is a rarity so I want to take
advantage of that so before before I go
into it and to figure out how quickly I
want to go into QA by show of hands how
many people here don't know much about
me and don't know much about my spiel
raise your hands okay that hurts fair
enough but that's what I thought okay
I'll give you the back backdrop I
apologize for some of my fans here that
have heard this first ten minutes but I
want to frame up the context for the
majority of you and then we'll go into
the State of the Union and then I'd love
to go into QA I was born you know it's
fun as an American I was born much
closer to here than where I live now I
was born in Belarus and the brusque not
too far away
I left the former Soviet Union in 1978
and moved to Queens New York in the
States I grew up in a very immigrant
upbringing six seven eight family
members in a studio apartment in Queens
New York it was a there was a tough time
in the US economy my dad did
construction in Russia and wasn't able
to get any jobs like that in the US so
the first solid paying job he was able
to get was a $2.00 an hour job being a
stock boy in a liquor store in New
Jersey
he eventually ascended to being the
manager of that store and we moved to
Edison New Jersey when I was five six
years old I am as pure bred of an
entrepreneur as you will find basically
since the time I was four or five six
years old the most interesting thing to
me in the world was selling stuff to
people when I was five six
I had three four or five lemonade stands
New Jersey and would spend my summer
days you know washing cars ripping
people's flowers out of their yard and
selling it back to them any anything to
make a buck finding random things in my
friends homes and selling it selling
selling selling selling when my you know
it's funny immigrants have a very good
strategy they save all their money spend
none of it and eventually buy something
and that's what my family did for the
first seven eight years of our lives in
the u.s. we lived very humbly and
eventually my dad bought a small liquor
store in in Springfield New Jersey I at
the age of 12 11 12 13 baseball cards
football card sports cards and
memorabilia were very big in the u.s. at
this point and I became a major
collector and seller and was making one
to two thousand dollars a weekend
selling baseball cards and so at that
point is a 13 year old I was very rich
there was a lot of money for a kid that
way and then my dad kind of ruined my
life when I turned 14 being the oldest
son you know in an immigrant family
merchant family you know first
generation he dragged me into the liquor
store and every weekend and every summer
vacation I had from the time that I was
in eighth grade 14 years old I spent in
the liquor store bagging I stocking
shelves I was a classic merchants son I
hated it I didn't want to sell beer
liquor but somewhere around the second
or third year of me being involved in my
family business I realized that people
collected wine and that was the first
time that I'd become interested in my
dad's business whether a sports
memorabilia or wine collecting and
selling that felt natural to me I became
fascinated and I went headfirst into
that business and decided that I was
going to join the family business
because hey I was a terrible student and
wasn't going to go that route and be I
really wanted to you know it's funny if
there's ever been a feeling in my life
that I'm more obsessed to it's that I
hate owing anybody anything I hate
asking it's a very Eastern European
thing I think you know I hate asking
I hate owing anybody a favor so extreme
that I felt that I even had to pay back
my parents for the life they were giving
me and I felt very compelled and very
pulled towards going into the family
business and helping it so my plan was
that I was going to open up you know as
a 17 year old who thought he was going
to be the biggest I said I'm going to
open up 2,000 wine stores across all of
America build the biggest franchise of
wine stores in America sell it one day
and buy the New York Jets American
football team and that was my strategy
what happened next is why I'm standing
here I was a freshman in college playing
video games Matt in 94 dominating by the
way and my friend came into the room and
he said you have to come and see this
now there's a lot of youngsters in this
room as I look around some of us that
have a little bit more gray hairs you
know in 1994 the Internet seemed like
fantasy it was something I'd read about
once or twice the information
superhighway this was not mainstream
obviously definitely not mainstream in
Eastern Western Europe and definitely
not mainstream in the US I walked into a
dorm room I heard crew couch which was a
sound of dial-up internet in America and
I sat and again I want it I want the
youngsters to listen to what I'm about
to say i sat in a room for six hours and
watched people on the Internet
it was interesting enough just to watch
somebody be on the Internet because it
was so crazy compared to what I grew up
with and I'd never seen anything like it
after six hours of watching guys spend
30 minutes at a time at their turn to be
on the internet I sat down six hours and
I went on an America Online bulletin
board and saw that people were selling
and trading baseball cards and within
the first ten minutes of my life ever
being on the internet it clicked in my
mind I said holy [ __ ] I don't need to
open up 2,000 stores I can do something
with this and for the next six seven
months of my life late 1994 early 1995 I
read and learned and when on the
internet went to the library which I
never did before to go on the Internet
try to figure out what is this thing
because this thing intuitively in my gut
I knew there was something here what
this led to was in 1996 a year later I
launched one of the first e-commerce
wine businesses in America
my father got ridiculed for letting me
spend the money to build this website
everybody thought that I should open a
second store not an e-commerce business
again youngsters in this room most
people most people who were 40 and older
in 1995 1994-1996 thought the internet
itself was a fad not snapchat not
Instagram the whole thing was a fad and
so for me this was the first time in my
career that I was fighting against the
system for the first time in my business
career I believed deeply religiously
blindly in something that everybody who
had more money who was older who'd been
around Vietnam disagreed with me this
became the theme and continues to be the
theme of my life which is the only thing
I care about and I say it up there I day
trade attention for me I'm not emotional
that Twitter is not a play in Romania it
means nothing to me
I just care about what is a play if I
want to sell something here I care what
is not what I wanted to be or what I
wish it would be or what I hope it would
be my friends in venture capital over
the next half decade are going to lose a
fortune in virtual reality consumer they
want all of us to be living in VR but
we're not not yet maybe in b2b maybe if
you go to an event maybe to go the
Olympics or a soccer match coca-cola you
put it on fine but nobody here is going
home tonight and putting on a VR headset
and spending three hours it's not what
we're doing yet nobody's doing that so
it doesn't matter to me if I'm excited
about snapchat or Instagram stories or
Facebook or Google the only thing I care
about is attention and in 1996 I
believed that people's attentions were
about to go into computers and that they
would buy stuff I took over my dad's
business in 1998 and in the five year
window from ninety
98 to 2003 on a business that had very
little profit my first year the entire
marketing budget was 15 to $20,000 for
the year and from 1998 to 2003 I built
that business from a four to a sixty
million dollar business all on the back
of everything that I want to talk about
today
back then it was email marketing how
many people here have done email
marketing in their career raise your
hands raise it high you're going to love
this in 1997 I had a two hundred
thousand person email newsletter selling
wine that had 91 percent open rates
don't clap I wasn't special it was that
nobody else was email marketing in 1996
how many people here had email in 1996
anybody raise your hands raise it high
okay so for the 50 of you you remember
what I remember in 1996 you read every
[ __ ] email and every word because my
friends more than I know that the Sun
will come up tomorrow I know that
marketers ruin every platform and in
1996 email had not been ruined yet and
that's why I had 91% open rates and I
built my business on the back of email
marketing while my competitors were
sending catalogs in the mail spending $7
to make a catalog and sent putting a
stamp on it
I had already sold the wine to those
people two weeks four weeks six weeks
earlier for zero cost and then a little
thing came along called Google and that
was good for me because they had an ad
product called Google Adwords and the
day that Google AdWords came out how
many people here have worked on Google
AdWords in their career figured the day
that Google AdWords came out I bought
every wine term you can imagine wine
Cabernet Napa Valley Bordeaux and it
cost me back then for the first seven
months the minimum was five cents a
click not ten cents a click so for the
first seven months that the Google
AdWords platform was out I owned the
majority of the 200 most searched wine
terms for five cents a click before
anybody bid me up
and so this became the pattern email
market at first actually having a
website then email marketing then Google
AdWords and I was rolling and I was
rolling and I was rolling and for all
intensive purposes I had made it right
we had a family liquor business now
we're a sixty million dollar company I
had to buy my car at a garage sale
my brother AJ got a brand-new Lexus we
made it right and then YouTube comes and
YouTube comes out and I look at it in
2005 and I say this is going to change
the world
I thought YouTube was going to be huge
and so within the first nine months of
YouTube being a platform I started a
show called Wine Library TV where in
2006 I used to sit in front of a camera
with four bottles of wine and for 20
minutes I would drink them this was the
first time in my career that I was
building an audience and then they were
buying wine for me on winelibrary.com
and was the first time ever that I was
selling product not by running
advertising but by doing content by
being a media company not by being an
advertiser and it hit me very seriously
but what hit me way more my friends was
that only a couple months later YouTube
sold to Google for 1.6 billion dollars
and to remind how many people were in
tech or meteor advertising in 2006 love
it so you guys remember that number
seemed like a trillion dollars we didn't
have two billion dollar X that would be
literally literally like if you woke up
tomorrow and saw that musically so for
1.5 trillion dollars it was massive it
seemed like so much money and I remember
waking up that morning and realizing you
know what eat website email Google
AdWords now YouTube's I have this talent
and it's the only times I have listened
I get to be the hottest speaker and then
I get all that smoke you're all here I
get it it's very funny to me and it's
something I want to talk to you about
it's about self-awareness what I really
want to talk to some of the
entrepreneurs in here is you need to
figure out who you are it blows my mind
that I am average
and extremely below average in so many
things most things almost everything but
there's one little thing I'm super good
at which is I'm unemotional around human
behavior I don't judge what you're going
to do I don't care where the world's
going I just watch what you do and I
move very quickly and in that intuition
and in that non-romantic point of view
in that unemotional it is what it is and
human beings evolved in that I have
found my career and I realized I had a
talent and I said to myself okay enough
website email Google AdWords YouTube
yes I've built a good wine company but
the next time I feel that feeling and
that's what it was all four of those
things just a feeling
just goosebumps just a feeling I said
the next time I feel that I'm going to
invest and become an angel investor
because the money is far greater than if
I sell some more Bordeaux and in 2007
and 2008 the first three companies I
felt bad for and invested in were called
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr yeah
that you can clap for so as you can
imagine that changed my career I made a
lot of money on paper I did really well
and then and then a very interesting
thing happened I took another step back
and I said Who am I as I got to know
Mark Zuckerberg and Ed Williams and then
met all the fancy B C's Chris Sacca and
Kushner and all these people I realized
I didn't look like any of them I was
definitely not going to invent the next
Facebook or tumblr I didn't see that and
to be very honest I'm not that
passionate about being an investor I'm
an operator I like doing I've done very
well I continued to invest I went on to
invest in Pinterest and snapchat and
uber I made I've done very very well I
do have that skill but I don't love it
what I love is building businesses what
I what I'm proud of is that I know a lot
of you follow me on Instagram and things
of that nature where it's motivational
like get up and do it and [ __ ] this and
[ __ ] that and did
I love that but what's much more
interesting to me is the fact that I've
gone out and done it right I went out
and built a 60 million dollar ecommerce
retail business in the last six years
I've built one of the fastest growing
digital advertising agencies in the
world I've built that literally from
zero to a hundred thirty million dollars
in revenue in six years I've done it
I've executed and so for me the
operations is what I wanted to do and so
what I'm in the middle of is I've built
vaynermedia this big agency but my dream
and why I built it is over the next
decade I'm going to go out and buy Apple
you know Cracker Jacks
I'm going to go out and buy CAD sneaker
I'm going to go out and buy brit san
pellegrino sparkling water I'm going to
go out and buy brands and then I'm going
to run them through my machine and I'm
going to mark it like it's 2020 not like
it's 2003 or 2005 what has been
fascinating for me in the last five to
seven years being on Madison Avenue at
can you know advertising festival being
in the agency landscape not in the
entrepreneur landscape is how much money
is being wasted how much money is being
poured into television and programmatic
banner and pre-roll digital assets an
ungodly amount of money is being thrown
directly in the trash we are living
through the greatest human shift in
communication since the radio to the
television this is the single biggest
shift in the way that we interact since
the late 40s and early 50s in the US and
a little bit later in other parts of the
world my friends this is it if you do
not story tell communicate mark it on
this device and on the eight or nine
platforms that dominate this advise you
are barely existing and that is
happening on an everyday basis it's not
that people don't see outdoor billboards
or print ads or television ads I'm fine
with that
everything potentially works I'm just
worried about what's under priced and
what's over priced to me
the punchline isn't what's working and
not working it's what appropriately
priced and under price that is why I
used the word day trade because for me
if snapchat is rolling in the US and
European markets for under 35 and it's a
good deal and the next day Instagram
decides to copy all of its features and
it slows down and that's fine by me if I
wake up tomorrow and find out that
Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
snapchat and tumblr and and and YouTube
and Google are gone no emotion for me as
a matter of fact that would be better
because that would mean that everybody
has to scramble to figure out where
everybody's attention is and I just have
no romance or no financial tie-in to
what I want it to be I just need to
figure out where it's going to be and so
I implore actually let me break this
down how many people here are
entrepreneurs and have their own company
raise your hand okay how many people
here work at an agency very nice how
many people at a corporation or a
company love it
so now that I've got that sense let's
talk a little bit about the third one
because there's a lot of hands one of
the things that I'm very fascinated by
is that I've a very interesting feeling
in my stomach what just have one more
time third one work in a company raise
your hands so this one's very
interesting to me as I look around and
get the feeling because I believe that
if you were here at this conference and
you work at a company you're in an
interesting spot and let me tell you
what that interesting spot is and I see
this every day around the world every
part of the world that I go to I believe
in my heart that you know what's
happening I believe that you know what's
happening I believe that if your
children's health was on the line that
you would spend the marketing dollars in
a very different way I feel that you're
in a machine that forces you to justify
your spending against reports or history
or your boss's boss point of view that's
thriving what you say in every meeting
but what you think in your head is
completely different
and to me this is the most fascinating
thing because let me tell you why I am a
human being so what's happened over the
last five years is the brand managers
and the CMOS and the people that I
interact with have become my friends I
like them you know obviously I want to
do business with them some move on some
of you work with but you become friends
it's human and what's become very very
upsetting to me is some of them are very
smart they understand what to do but
they're just saying what they're
supposed to say so they get a promotion
or so they don't get fired and what I
keep trying to remind them and what's
about to happen in the corporate
landscape over the next five to seven
years as this whole world changes is
these companies are making you say
certain things in the room based on the
current rules when it's not going to
work over next to four to five years
they're going to fire you for agreeing
with it and that sucks and so if I can
leave you for nap now that I think about
it I always think about this a long
schlep you know obviously I'm very
thankful for getting paid but you know I
I've got a lot of business to be running
and so obviously I'm here mainly because
to be very honest I'm here for a couple
reasons one I love the swagger of the
organizers and how they came at me to to
- and probably even a little bit more
I've just been dying to come here and
visit your amazing country and city so
thank you for having me
and then and then and that's why I want
to do QA and then when I fly home
tomorrow morning first thing I'll really
know why I came it's going to be one
question one answer one feeling but the
one that's leading right now is if I can
get one person in this room that is now
I realize predominantly people that are
employees yet again if you're here
understand what's actually happening if
I can get one of you to have the courage
and I don't want to get anybody I don't
need anybody emailing me in four months
saying [ __ ] you Gary I got fired not
interested not interested don't email me
I'm not that you live your life but I'm
going to give you a very good piece of
advice if you can figure out how
respectfully whether in the room after
work at drinks at a holiday party
somewhere someway make sure everybody
knows where you stand in your head on
where the world is not what you're
saying to appease the Machine because
it's going to be that one conversation
with that one person that gives you an
opportunity three or four or five years
from now and you have to be historically
correct I am very proud that I built
vaynermedia from 0 to 130 million in six
years I just want you all to understand
Romania I could have built vaynermedia
from 0 to 400 million in the last six
years but I refuse at all costs to not
be historically correct being
historically correct is the biggest ROI
in life let alone business and I know
again by those hands and by what's
actually going on in the world at this
moment that so many of you are being put
in a position to be historically
incorrect at a very difficult time in
where you are in your careers and you
will curtail your upside so please if
you believe something figure out how to
communicate it proper
respectfully because it is the biggest
asset you have your points of view your
thoughts your ideas your passions in
what's actually happening because I
promise you I promise you I know most of
you do not believe in the majority of
what you're spending your advertising on
it's just what's happening you can't be
a common sense individual you can't have
half a brain and believe in what's
actually happening right now we are
living through the greatest era of
wasted money in marketing ever because
we're in the decline of traditional in
the rise of digital 80% of the digital
assets are complete [ __ ] garbage
because nobody here wants to go to a
website look on the right side scroll
down and look at the banner ad on the
right nobody here went to go see that
YouTube video of somebody skiing and was
excited about watching a car pre-roll
run for the first 13 seconds nobody
consumed that we do not talk enough
about the actual impact of a CPM on the
brand there are brands that I no longer
buy because they bother me so much
digitally and steal my time when I'm on
my mobile device let me tell you what's
the worst thing in the world a pop up a
mobile pop up on a cell phone it takes
up the entire screen the [ __ ] X is
this small I try to exit but of course
you [ __ ] hit the ad by accident back
home at the brand in the agency they're
like yeah two percent click-through
meanwhile meanwhile every time I click
those ads I literally mentally say thank
you I mentally say to myself I am never
buying that sneaker brand again and so
we're having a very undereducated
conversation around marketing we have
two factions we have the traditional and
a couple weeks I'm going to go to can
right and I'm going to want to shoot
myself in the head because it's
thousands of people who just dream about
the video and think it's the greatest
thing and this [ __ ] statue is their
life and it didn't sell any [ __ ]
product [ __ ]
and then a week later I'll go to Silicon
Valley and check in on some of my
startups and these startups and all it
is is math nerds who think all of
marketing is math let me just tell you
math nerds real quick let me tell the
camera math nerds
if marketing was math it would be over
by now it's not [ __ ] math so what we
need to do in marketing is we need to
take the best of both worlds
we need the art [ __ ] in kanne and
the math [ __ ] in Silicon Valley to
have sex and have a child and that's
what I think about every day for me
marketing is very simple it comes down
to what am I trying to accomplish am i
trying to sell this sneaker am I trying
to raise money for a cause
am I trying to get somebody elected what
am I trying to do what what is my goal
and to me when that becomes a thing that
becomes the KPI not the weekly reporting
that is math guys Google is the
Tollbooth of the internet it gets all
the extra credit that it does not
deserve because of consumers behavior
you may see a billboard outside that
makes you go to Google because that's
your search behavior to get to the
website and it gets the credit last
touch attribution for all the people
that are in this is such a horseshit
metric yet we trade on it CPM cost being
the reason you do something is insane
when the hell was the cost of something
the direct attribution to its value
never and so we're in a very interesting
time meanwhile 80 billion dollars in the
u.s. is poured into television ads when
I looked at the data coming to Romania
the amount of dollars still spent
traditionally is very high there's
nobody there's nobody on earth who's
watching television commercials guys
they don't exist even your [ __ ] 90
year old grandma when the commercial
comes on she grabs her cell phone and
text to honey I miss you
it's true the attention the attention is
what matters can you honestly tell me
that the people that you're trying to
reach in this great country or the
surrounding countries to sell your
product do you actually think they're
paying attention to a commercial do you
think billboards of globally outdoor
media cost and last four years is up 12%
globally up meanwhile every passenger in
every car in the world no longer looks
outside there's not a single passenger
in any vehicle that looks outside every
person here if they're a passenger or
take public transportation on the way
home today will not give a view to an
outdoor piece of content that they would
have 20 years ago because they would
have looked out there they were gonna go
Gary was amazing oh look a brand you
know now they're here 24/7 and to be
very honest I don't know if you've
noticed even the drivers are paying
attention to this it's never been
scarier to drive and so I just am
fascinated and I'm so grateful and I and
I and I remind people here who've been
in the game a little bit or for people
that are quite young and just starting
out we are very lucky this is a very
specific time again globally the 1950s
to 2015 65 years globally every markets
different obviously I'm very familiar
with the Soviet regimes and different
things but globally they're 65 years
print radio television Direct Mail
outdoor like very consistent you didn't
have to be a rocket scientist very easy
to go to school and figure it out
storytelling had been figured out goal
you know what's very fun go to youtube
and type in the first television
commercials the first hundred television
commercials were actually radio ads
because we just came from radio the
first hundred television ads was a
picture like that and a man standing
behind it and reading a radio ad we as
marketers as business people hadn't
figured out how to use the medium yet
that's what's happening on Facebook
right now Facebook is the greatest
marketing tool
that the world has ever seen right now
when I looked at the cost of advertising
here because I knew I was coming the
Facebook awareness the Facebook ad
product in this country is so grossly
underpriced compared to the alternatives
it is staggering I opened an office in
London because of Europe's collective
massive underpricing
of the Facebook marketplace you know
what's you know it's really good kids
when you get a little older and so
losing a little hair you see patterns
this is what happened in Google when I
looked at Google in 2004 when I came to
be on a wine buying trip I went to go
run some ads while I was in Bordeaux for
Wine Library but I didn't realize
because it was late 2 o'clock in the
morning I was in the French add product
and when I went to go play SADS they
were so inexpensive I got excited I
didn't realize that I'd stumbled into
wait a minute they are so much more
under priced here because what's amazing
about Facebook and Google that is not
amazing about television print and CPM
costs on digital media products is it's
a real marketplace everything else has a
bottom cost which means it can be
inflated for its value the market is the
market so in Facebook and in Google it's
just the market whatever was somebody's
willing to pay becomes the next feeling
of price right now the far majority of
people in this room and in this country
are grossly under estimating the value
of Facebook ad the truth is a lot of
people in this room have opinions on
Facebook ads but they've never run a
Facebook ad campaign there's a lot of
talking and not a lot of doing or you
did it once and you made your decision
without any variations or really
understanding what's happening so
Facebook ads are massively under priced
to reach the end consumer here massively
by the way but what's more important is
what are you going to say once you get
in front of them what's the picture
what's the video and that is where the
new art form is being defined the new
battle for the people that go to France
for awards will be played in the one two
three four five six minute videos on
Facebook
no longer confined to the 30 seconds or
15 seconds of a TV ad long-form video on
Facebook many people here when they
think about social media marketing or
Facebook videos they think it should be
short all the action isn't long if you
actually have somebody stay for two
minutes and 18 seconds you can sell them
you can't get as many people to stay but
I'd much rather have seventy thousand
people watch 2 minutes and 18 seconds
than have 7 million people watch 4
seconds right and so I am very excited
for all the creatives here the people
that want a story tell because the next
3 to 5 years this group of individuals
we us who are in the game today are
going to define what a Facebook
commercial is and I promise you it will
not feel like a television commercial it
will not feel like a branded video it
will feel like a sitcom or a documentary
or a music video it will be something
that people want to watch because unlike
television Facebook gives us feedback
and we can see if people like it or not
and we will adjust to that and that will
be the battle frontier the two frontiers
for the winners in this room are going
to be Facebook long-form video and
influencer marketing on Instagram and
other platforms I promise you when I
come back here in 3 years and we do an
update that the six of you that actually
went on the offense on Facebook
advertising and creative and on
influencer marketing will win that is
where the dollars will shift over the
next five years there'll be plenty of
money you're going to say but in this
country but my clients I get it
[ __ ] you it's going to happen it's not
going to happen tomorrow the most
progressive brands in America are still
holding on to their gear television or
banner ads not because they believe in
it but because the media holding
companies are selling it and the media's
holding companies are selling it because
that's where their profit margin isn't
but this is what always happens this is
not my opinion this is just data last
year 97% of
the fortune 500 CPG brands in the world
declined in market share because they
are not marketing to the reality of 2017
and so the stakes are high and this
plays through for entrepreneurship as
well if your startup your opportunity
has never been greater your competitors
have a lot more money than you they're
much further along than you let me
remind you all you startups why guys
like me and you and gals like you are
going to win
because big companies get really [ __ ]
stupid and even slower and your
advantage of speed and actually dealing
in reality and so the framework of our
attention these eyes and these ears wait
to see what happens with the emergence
of podcasts in this country over the
next three to four years right now a
blip on the screen but the number one
reason Hoover became a monster company
is because it sells time the number one
thing that everybody in this room values
besides health and money is time and
what voice does Alexa voice podcast is
it saves you time sound is a time saver
in many situations and I believe that
sound both in podcasts and the future
Alexa Voice Google home smart home voice
activated is going to emerge over the
next decade as well and I implore you to
become smart about that because I
believe being one of the first things
that you listen to in the morning from
Alexa voice five years from now is like
being the first organic result for your
business on Google fifteen years ago it
is a battleground of attention in his
open property
it's whoever smart enough and hungry
enough to go learn it build an Alexa
skill market it and emerge as a leader
in that attention my friends attention
arbitrage where is the actual attention
what's the [ __ ] metrics that make
people waste money
what's the politics the bosses the
infrastructure that makes people waste
big dollars and where is your
opportunity to strike if you are able to
understand that framework and religion
the upside of your career happiness and
ability to communicate becomes maximized
and good news in the 20 years that I've
been marketing there's been two eras the
Google era which was really 1999 2000
2001 I was really 2001 to 2004 when it
was so underpriced let me give you a
couple of companies that were the
biggest spenders on Google in the early
Google era Amazon eBay these are the
companies that one how many people here
are familiar with wish the shopping app
raise your hands let me just say there's
a company called wish if you open your
Apple Store right now it's one of the
top 150 apps the shopping app this
company's gone from zero to two billion
dollars in retail sales in the last five
years on 100% the back of Facebook this
is now the Facebook era it's Facebook
and Instagram
it is unbelievable scale and
ridiculously under priced and in this
little window companies like wish that
other things will be talked about in the
20 years that I've spent religiously 15
hours a day trading attention there's
only been two moments like this Google
and we're in one right now
I implore you to not look back at the
speech that I gave here as when you
heard about it but you didn't do
anything about it and you have to wait
another 7 to 10 years for another era so
I beg you I beg you to take advantage of
this phenomenal conference and go do
something about it tomorrow thank you
thank you so I think this is probably on
right is this on good yeah huh yeah nice
anybody got a question guys ready let's
do it
we're Gary how are you can you hear me
yeah amazing what's your name
hush hush I'm from Slovenia very nice
and I have a question actually I totally
agree with you you are saying all the
time that we need to deliver value more
value that we need we ask in return the
same money in this case Yeah right or
for attention right you're you're asking
for 15 seconds of my time I [ __ ] want
my 15 seconds right so what are you
gonna put in front of me so you're
absolutely right it's a value exchange
in life always and as business marketers
and brands that's right that is my
religion 5149 I'm gonna give you more
uh-huh then I ask for in return thank
you okay but like if you're in a market
yes people don't value what you do then
you're a deep [ __ ] yeah I know but
listen to me everybody needs it it's
marketing basically it's creating
content
everybody needs content but people don't
realize how much they need it they like
you know I don't know what I'm talking
about the thing is how leaden you gotta
go thanks for coming all right okay I'm
gonna give you a very good piece of
advice it's the number one read so don't
forget and this is probably where we
have a kinship I've been selling stuff
nobody wants my whole life right the way
I built the wine business everybody in
America was already big on Bordeaux
Italy in California
I sold mainly Australia New Zealand
Spain Croatian wines I was going all
over the world and so the number one
thing if you're telling me that people
aren't putting enough value on the
creative the number one thing I can tell
you is don't sell to the unsellable what
I would do if I were you is I was
literally in this whole thing are you
interested in weigh them nope no no no
kinda okay you have a talk no okay no no
to me the key is there are people that
value it you just need to cast a very
wide net when you're selling something
that you perceive is not
valued enough and instead of being
emotional and trying to convince him and
spend two days three weeks a month
convincing him [ __ ] him and go to the
next person
all right Cheers and because yeah you
understand yeah I've watched it my whole
life like trying to sell to somebody
who's already not sellable
it's where readers or pioneers get
killed yeah I was actually trying to ask
how do you motivate than your team who
has who doesn't think like that and I
don't have time to listen to you let's
say so how do you motivate them when you
kid I make them have time to listen to
me all right and number two I instill it
through my own confidence and you try to
figure out who's willing to come with
you and who's not a lot of people
struggle you know you know this how you
said a little bit like [ __ ] your client
won't do it I have that major problem I
took all you know my vlog four or five
episodes ago you see 70 of them sitting
in my tent right and I'm just killing
them for six hours guys your clients
saying there was not an excuse like
that's just not an excuse you know like
you've got to convince them we get paid
to think too not just the output of our
pictures and videos and so it's hard man
it's not fun to sell something that
isn't sellable but if you end up being
correct in the long term it's far more
fruitful than succumbing to the current
but I would tell you to not spend time
on people that say no clients and
employees thank you you're welcome
and since evaluate time yes a bottle of
wine for my father very nice thank you
it's a bowl over the wine from Slovenia
from a small village
thank you very much sell it we don't do
anything with it just right for our
friends and family and drink it with
somebody you love thank you my friend
going to make whatever sir thank you
thank you
who's got it oh jesus thank you thanks I
get it hi what's your name my name is
Eugene I'm from Ukraine nice just close
to Belarus perfect the same my language
yes we did yeah and a few years ago I
read your book lash it and I quit my job
and
yeah and I became and I became
intrapreneur and this is the best thing
which happens in my life so thanks
thanks a lot
you're welcome but that's a very
specific question sure I've seen you
start to do Fitness a lot yes and few
things you said that if you would spend
your time except for the work you would
do more for health and wellness so the
question is if you would do and maybe
you already do in entering the fitness
industry which is huge in u.s. and over
the world what you would do what would
we do your steps so I think I think the
thing that I'd probably think a lot
about is when I look at so I'm not in
the health and wellness or fitness
industry personally we work with a
couple of them I've looked at it as a
consumer program and by the way I have
some insight into it from the business
lens that I'll give you I'll give you a
very good answer I would very much
triple down on AI the amount of
opportunity in fitness specifically
around AI because so much is information
and so much of the overhead of deploying
information is held in humans that is
commoditized if I was to bet right now
on a big opportunity within Fitness and
just a big opportunity inside of
information AI is going to eat up so
much opportunity so I would think about
a lot about message box voice like how
do you deploy the information in a way
that's more consumable do you know
pallet on the bike company no I see some
people shaking their head it's a bike
that has a big screen and instead of
going to the studios that it becomes so
popular and doing like they created you
know in essence the operating system
right they can keep changing the content
and with a very simple you know
technology shift
they built a billion-dollar business I
think message bots in the new
environment things of that nature an app
that's automated I think I would really
look at what's going on in AI and
augmented the information at scale
because there's so much that's being
created on information in that space and
it's so inefficient in the technologies
that are now at our fingertips okay
thank you you got it once you pass it to
somebody
okay I like the underhand okay sorry
no problem you got it you got to look it
up what we did oke who is coming in New
York d-roc oh where is he right where is
the rice where do I love you oh they are
d-roc let's cheer up for deer ah hello
doc so I would like to ask you what are
what's your name
speedos I'm from Greece how are you or
everything all day thank you I love you
and I love you okay
so I would like to ask you what are the
top three skills that a young man like
me 22 years old need to focus really
focus not the [ __ ]
the number one thing you need more than
anything is patience I know I know it is
it's it's right right the number one
threat I mean I know you know you just
don't want to deploy it no the end I
mean I can give you two other [ __ ]
ones but I promise you the things that
work are very simple patience for
anybody how many people under 30 raise
your hand
[ __ ] listen if I could give you guy you
know if I could tell you one thing and
I'm looking around seeing the other
people and how many people over 45 what
every one of us you know what all about
them would tell you is if you understood
how young we still feel you feel the
same you feel this I'm 41 and I feel
exactly the same that I did at 22 same
fire same energy same hunger same
opportunity I'm just wiser more
experienced I've seen things if I could
tell you what it felt like to be 41 you
would become dramatically more patient
if you became more patient you would
become more successful because when
you're patient you do things that are
tried-and-true and you don't take the
shortcuts that lead to problems the
other thing I would say is
self-awareness I think the biggest thing
that I wish on everybody is
self-awareness because if you know
yourself you know the biggest problem I
have with the current world is everybody
thinks
nor because it's cool everybody has
decided that they're a founder and so
there'll be a lot of people who start
terrible companies and will fail who
could have gone and got great jobs and
end up being number five number 11
number 13 and a great company and had a
great life but instead are going to be
number one of [ __ ] have to start at 27
all over have a loss a scarlet letter
right have the depression that comes
along with the loss so I would say
patience and self-awareness and then
third it's the biggest thing that you
have right now would you have time and
so what I would do at that time as I
would [ __ ] work right like I'm you
know ultimately if you deploy number two
and know yourself you'll know how big or
how medium or how decent you want your
career to work out but the thing that
has fascinated me is how many people's
actions don't back up what their mouth
is saying all these people telling me
that they're going to be millionaires
and billionaires and they don't work any
weekend no oxidant that gets snow you
know so they're all there you know
listen you follow my stuff I think I
didn't give you anything you haven't
heard before but the big ones patience
because I know twenty three-year-old
dudes that live in Greece that are will
in a slip here they're hungry and
balancing hunger with patience is an
extremely difficult thing to do but you
know I'm not giving you advice from a
high horse I put my head down from 22 to
33 years old before I talk to anybody
and actually build a business first
worth 18 hours a day in a liquor store
and then came out and started doing
other stuff so I eat in that [ __ ] that
patience it [ __ ] you know what patience
tastes like [ __ ]
but it is the number one formula to
success something else I'd understand
this this day yes everyone's talking
about podcast about sound about door
listing so tell me I know that you have
a BA graphic a you are trying to for
personal development marketing
everything how abroad can make a podcast
coca-cola can make a podcast easy
coca-cola needs to make a podcast and
what they need to do is instead of
spending a trillion dollars being the
sponsor of the World Cup they need to
spend ten million dollars getting the
three best soccer football personalities
in the world to be the host of their
show and they become ESPN or CNN or CNBC
like you need to become the media
company when you are the brand so
coca-cola should have the number one
football podcast in the world and then
all that attention goes to coca-cola if
you have to shift and become a media
company and that's what I'm doing I'm
not necessarily Gary B I'm trying to be
Wall Street Journal fortune Fast Company
Inc you know that's what my strategy is
okay thank you very much welcome just
got a question hey Gary
hello don't worry I've got some serious
time we're good to go
I was interested in a long Q&A okay go
ahead my friend
yeah my name is PN and I have you you
talked a lot about work ethic so you got
to work hard to get things done yes but
I feel like I've got the next big idea
but then there's simply not enough time
for one person to get everything done in
the time that matters so like what do
you what advice do you have for me to
like where do I look for like-minded
people to start kicking ass yeah so what
do you look so what are you looking when
you say like-minded people are you
looking for developers are you looking
for a project leads like what are the
assets you need those like-minded people
and skills that they have to bring like
I have an idea that I can found it on
the first face yeah I got money to hire
people yeah it's just that I don't know
where to look for the best talent so
that fits each category like I need the
developers I need the project managers
and I need the social media guys or
girls yep and I just I just yeah where
to look I'm gonna give you a great idea
so there's a website you know we're
having right
the best part about my fans is they know
what I'm saying before I say it because
I believe in the same [ __ ] over and over
my man if you have the next big idea and
you're not capable of going to Google
and finding your people you don't have
the next big idea all right then
do you understand its execution so so
finding finding developers or these
people literally as Google like do you
live here or work would you like yeah I
live in Iranian now literally you like
literally if today was my first day
living in this country I would just go
to google and type in Romanian
developers and I would spend four hours
clicking different websites and signing
[ __ ] like it's so easy to find find if
there's not enough skill developers in
Romania which I don't believe but but by
the way let's say you're all wrong and
she's right here's good news here's good
news you don't need a developer to be
here to work with them so whether you
find them in there's unlimited platforms
right to find individuals it's called
the Internet literally it is Google not
really I know it's a you know what
sometimes you just need to hear it this
way right like there's there's
developers anywhere let me give you
another one let me give you another one
go to angel list right do you know what
that is yeah great go to every one of
those founders and VCS and cold email
them and say hey bro I'm me I'm trying
to start this company
I need development and project
management help let me tell you what's
going to happen you're going to spend
five and a half hours emailing 800
people and only two of them are going to
reply the good news is they're going to
send you in the right direction if you
emailed me at Gary at vaynermedia right
and said I need development help I would
send you two six people that I know have
outsourced teams in Ecuador in India in
other parts of the world like my friends
not knowing where to find it not finding
like-minded people there's not enough
talent in this country this town these
are just [ __ ] excuses it's what it is
all right don't wait excuses it is
listen you you live in a world today
nice we live you really screwed that
nice lady you want to send it back and
then we'll go back to you yeah my friend
kids it's once it's there you just got
to go hunt for it listen we all have
strengths and weaknesses right like
putting together two team that's new for
you you're a young man but it's out
there email people for help find
individuals like I went on Twitter and
search the hashtag to this event and saw
a lot of people that were talking about
this event and when I looked at their
profile the people in this room are some
of the people that can help you get to
the talent you're looking for you need
to get out of the roadblock of that I
can't find it and you just go and find
it cool you got it hey thank you you're
welcome
my name is Ekaterina how are you learn
from Bulgaria very nice fine and I'm
very glad to be here thank you I would
like to continue with the previous
question okay you talked about your
company as a honey Empire yes so how you
choose your leaders and how you control
to keep your focus and to your value to
follow your values
sure so so for summit thank you for
knowing that then you should paying
attention I've coined a phrase and
taught in my company called honey Empire
it Maps what my ambition is which is I
want to build a multi-billion dollar
organization and kill everybody and put
everybody out of business and you know
like that's that's business right that's
the game but I want to do it in a honey
way honey over vinegar internally it's
very important to me that everybody gets
along
not because I'm Mother Teresa but
because I believe that when people get
along you go faster when there's less
politics you're spending more time on
doing and not sitting at your desk
debating why Karen is trying to ruin you
right and so the the way I so it is it
has always been my belief it's the
biggest way that I turned my family
business and grew it so greatly so many
people here can be empathetic to this I
into my dad's store and he was running
it like Soviet Russia right he was
running it where he didn't trust his
employees he didn't like this employees
like again like a lot of people may know
here you know in a communist environment
everything is black market and you don't
trust and that's what it was and then
when I came in it's not my natural
demeanor I flipped in and I saw the
benefits very quickly and it's been and
in general I just like positivity I'm
crippled by negativity so for me a
couple things when I pick leaders I talk
to them upfront and say listen you could
be the greatest chief creative officer
of all time all time you can make the 50
greatest ads of all time but if you're
an [ __ ]
you're going to get fired right and I
say this and I and listen some people
are leaving big jobs big and i and i
emotionally say listen to me
you could get fired in four months and
it's going to look awkward on your
resume and you're gonna have to always
explain it please believe me when I tell
you because I know you've gone to other
places and they tell you it matters but
what really matters is the money right
and for me because I'm the best at
making the money I don't need you right
so you need to be that and so what I do
is I do that with everybody and then I
don't go through some big test or some
process I go on intuition and then if
they deliver Mazel Tov and if they don't
I fire them and so the way I'm able to
keep it is my actions have to back up my
words so over the last six years I fired
somebody recently who is a very senior
hire who barely worked for us like he
was there for 40 seconds but it didn't
work and then I'm empathetic and I gave
him a six-month severance because I felt
like it really disrupted his life so
it's not about the dollars but you can't
[ __ ] with my culture so it's about
setting the bar but your answer is the
answer to your question is very simple
you have to back up your words if I talk
the nice game and honey Empire and did
it a but back home it was poison I'd be
finished so I just I just really really
try now the same token you have to audit
and really make sure you know you know
you're not just jumping to one person
saying there
because they might be undermined it's a
lot of work to figure out your writing
sometimes you have to make a judgment
call but I spend more time on HR than
anything else I do more than sales more
than being Gary be more than selling
more than anything more than the product
services the majority of my time is
spent on HR this I landed here
I took a two-hour nap right now I woke
up for the thirty minutes before I got
here it was all HR this person this this
person's feelings that this person's
mother passed away which is devastating
like what are we going to do like all HR
HR HR HR HR the world is human the
people are the game so actions backing
up the words because there's a lot of
people who are good people and [ __ ]
awesome at what they do
thank you my name is Emmanuel to get you
next hey Manuel my company builds sports
facilities sports fields around the
country we've done a few projects
outside it's not the most digital and
sexy field most of our customers are
seasoned entrepreneurs big corporations
and quite a few mayor's which are over
45 yes on average so we do Google pretty
good we do Facebook and content and ads
we do offline marketing online marketing
we're better than our competitors but we
are not using half of the platforms you
have behind you on the screen so well
you definitely don't have to use
snapchat because it's not happening here
yet that's at that age group and
decision makers yeah we were thinking of
Instagram but kids are using Instagram
here and they've clear doing a lot of
effort to promote on Instagram we will
be promoting to kids who would never buy
okay what is your recommendation what
should we do to to take advantage of do
you do more right so if I was looking at
your business from what I've heard so
far a couple things stand out one this
is just general advice for everybody
make sure you don't position anything
too deeply into kids because in 12 or 24
months it becomes older and you want to
have a foot in that door so I
Instagram is at this point work through
a while because I looked at instagrams
data here and its aging up very very
very quickly
and I would predict in 24 months it's a
main player and so the same if you like
what's happening for you on Facebook
it's something to consider doing a
little just making sure you're there
just a presence uh but here's what I
would do I would probably use Facebook
very aggressively against the
advertising capability of employees of
organizations or against individuals
that you know you're targeting and what
I would do if I were you actually is I
would go into the events business let me
explain what I mean by that based on
what I'm hearing from you I would
probably use social media and digital
advertising and heck above the line
traditional advertising as a gateway
drug to private dinners and mini
conferences what I love about b2b
businesses especially when it's big
decisions big dollars small groups of
people is I want to get them in so for
me the wine-tasting or conference that
look like this for all the mayors and
entrepreneurs and business people once a
quarter once a year using one of the
things we've done for very big b2b plays
that are more infrastructure plays like
that is we've used Facebook to create to
be an invitation to a very premium event
got them there and you know after a
little bit of Rose egg from Slovenia you
know alcohol is an incredible gateway
drug to a big deal so you mean use it
just just as a just as a way to get in
contact with them to get in touch with
them and back to the great statement
that was said here if you're offering
them an exclusive first 25 people that
register go to this wonderful place with
this wonderful meal with this wonderful
event or speaker or performance they
just come in droves and we've been able
to very successfully because of Facebook
Ads underpriced we've been able to get
small private events we're selling 5 10
15 million-dollar apartments on Facebook
by targeting high net worth individuals
inviting them to high end dinners and
then click and then and then the company
takes over and closes two or three does
this happen only locally like in their
cities or you call them
to a different city like 300 kilometers
away so I would tell you that it depends
on the creative of the evening right if
you get the most famous [ __ ] person
on earth people will go anywhere right
so I think you have to map what are you
offering them right if it's you know if
you're if you're pouring 1982
first-growth Bordeaux they may go a
little further you know I think you've
got to figure out what the value prop is
compared to the distance and make it
worth their while to come it's just a
value exchange 5149 if you create but
what's really great is you could go big
I like small I like the eighth person
dinner series once every two weeks get
them into your confines bring them value
you know those mayor's those
entrepreneurs they have similar themes
and things they care about bring content
or speaker or performance or information
that's valuable to them holistically not
even even if it's about tax reform has
nothing to do with your stadium building
but you brought them value you're the
host you're there and away you go
okay one more short question have like
on Instagram what we what we do on
Facebook mostly we promote the beautiful
projects that we build or which is you
know do you do that in video form yes
great we do that also well we what would
we do on Instagram if you would just put
beautiful pictures of our beautiful
project projects or that will be too
boring and people wouldn't follow us my
intuition is that you're way way way way
better off going after the first thing
we just talked about put your energy and
dollars into that let instrument get a
little older I would create an account
and start you know there's a carousel
product now yeah we're using that okay
great so if you have if you have a
four-minute video you can chop that up
right into four one-minute videos on the
carousel AB I've been playing with that
I like the results that I'm seeing so I
would do that but I want you just set a
presence on Instagram for when they all
come just so you're used to it and ready
and the algorithm likes you but I would
put a lot of effort into real-life
interaction thank you very much you're
welcome get it to this guy over here
nice hi Gary works you know my name is
Vasily I really went in two years old
from Russia but I lived in us for the
past six years and I graduated from
University in u.s. I want to say thank
you so much for all your content I've
been watching you since September 2016
and every single day i watch daily v
askgaryvee show
I'm very active on 60-second Club - it
hasn't had I had a chance to win yet but
definitely all your support all the
advice has helped me to grow my business
I'm became fiber top-rated seller and
also my friend I was able your
recommendation to draw influencers we
were able to generate $100,000 in two
months on e-commerce only with
influencers so yes I want to make sure
everybody heard that the absolute best
trade besides Facebook ads in the world
our influencers on Instagram I assume
just mr. guy's DMing people on Instagram
who fit the profile of bringing
awareness to your products and services
I mean tell them is like oh yeah we we
GM 325 people and us was very overpriced
who went outside a little bit the prices
were much lower and the higher the lower
like 10,000 20,000 followers are under
priced so we used them and we got about
40 50 influencers out of 305 we DM and
this just wouldn't you pay them we paid
in the figure okay how much do you think
you paid for this it was defense some of
them were able to get for $200 and they
had like almost 2 million followers and
that's converted to like $700 value for
our e-commerce so how much do you spend
overall on them we spent over all around
20% of the those hundred thousand
dollars so you spent $20,000 yes to
drive people to an e-commerce site that
generated $100,000 in sales correct cool
and Mike Mike Elijah everyone thought
that was the first time you hadn't even
even tried that right uh I've tried
before I'm on the fiber I'm doing insert
marketing but I haven't really got that
Deb but since I was listening you every
single conference you talk about
influencers I've been literally with my
friend was said there and made a plan
and start DMing every single person and
it paid in their long-term so cool I
have a question so my question is as
being younger entrepreneur and start
hiring at people yeah and for example if
I start hire all their people and me
does it could it bring a negative impact
because I'm young no do you recommend to
build up also a younger team maybe worry
okay it's not super different than the
answer I gave you which is there's some
42 year old people that would not like
working for you because you're 22 but
good news it's you know it's a new day
now you're not forcing them to work for
you right so they said yes in the first
place which means 80% likely that they
were already okay with it other than
they desperately needed a job so for me
whether you build with 16 year olds or
you build with 44 year olds number one I
don't assume that 20 year olds gets
social media marketing better than a 40
year old some 20 year olds I think that
they're more native to it because it's
all they live on but that doesn't mean
they're better marketers or operators
there's plenty of I'm 41 years old I
think I'm the best in the world at it
right so I don't I don't think age is
the proxy I think it's the DNA of the
person you just have to try I don't
think there's a good piece of advice
other than don't be crippled by who you
hire make sure that when it doesn't work
that you're good at firing everybody
takes so much pride in how good they are
at hiring it's very hard I have a lot of
intuitive skills it's what I trade on my
EQ is everything I've got and I have
hired so many [ __ ] and I [ __ ] up
so many times it's embarrassing the key
is not having pride when you made a
mistake and being able to move on and
doing the right thing by them so they
can go on with their career but not but
also doing the right thing
which is your number one responsibility
for your business yeah thank you so much
and uh also for example for now do you
think it's a good idea to travel to
other events hear speakers for example
I'm planning to attend other events and
potentially your events like in Hong
Kong and you'll be speaking Frankfurt do
you recommend to invest my time and be
able to depends on what kind of learner
you are so in my 20s and 30s I went to
this many conferences but it doesn't
mean that I'm right or wrong
it means that there was a reason that I
didn't do well in school I don't learn
by listening
I only learn by doing so I I deployed
self-awareness and I decided not to be
business books not to go to conferences
and lectures I just did did did did so
but if you feel like you get value out
of it it's just value exchange if you
feel like you've got you know the best
part of a conference is this the number
one ROI of this conference for all of
you is the people that have courage here
and say hello to the other people here
the relationships are dro I like-minded
people in the game like as fun as this
is and I'm sure some people have wanted
to see me speak and I'm trying to do my
best year to really bring it I promise
you saying hello to the person next to
you and like if you want to do me one
huge favor as soon as I'm done here say
hello to two or three people the
business development opportunities are
enormous so I would go to Hong Kong in
those places to biz dev and if you learn
this way then of course anything that
helps you learn and get better is great
we all have different ways but you don't
just do it because somebody told you to
read books or go to conferences or
somebody told you to just do you need to
know yourself
thanks so much get again it can I shake
your hand sir can you pass up
the question I've been lucky at skinning
it okay all right listen
thank you hi Gary hi hi everyone
bit nervous and what's your name my name
is Stacy Stacy
so I've traveled here from the UK
because my friend Langer was talking
today and how do you do shishi I'm sorry
how'd you do [ __ ] phenomenal we met
actually online last year I spent 2,000
pounds last year I spent 2,000 pounds on
face book boosting my videos are about
20 minutes long on Facebook live before
it was trendy and I reached multiples
have multiple six figures by the end of
the year thank you my question to you is
this obviously a lot of more people are
doing videos but I know I go on for
quite a while in my videos and lots of
people watch me I recently featured in
Forbes because I help people do live
Facebook flies how do I get them how do
I get more people instantly the
conversion seems to be great but I see
your videos I watch you all the time
because of you actually I went in on to
video instead of like bothering with
copy my question to you is how can I get
even bigger
beyond the boosting in the facebook ads
and I actually contacted your team I do
events people come from New Zealand just
to meet me like you said for four hours
and what would be your tips from what
I've just said I think the two things
that over-index
or patience and quality okay right like
like I think one thing that a lot of us
forget is when we're asking people to
watch us we have to be bringing value
and so not everybody is going to build
the biggest audiences in the world so
it's a balance between the quality of
what you put out and patience how long
have you been doing it for maybe a the
tea is now right so you've been in it
it's what's built you a base but the
truth is do you don't my Instagram
profile my constraint profile has gone
from 400,000 to 1.8 million in the last
six months right I've been putting out
content on the internet for 10 years
and now just now it's starting to kind
of happen at a bigger scale right and
I'm really good at what I do I think we
forget how long of a game it is I'm
pumped that you said two years because
for a lot of people here who've been
doing it for three months and have the
same questions I grew to two years right
but when I hear two years from you like
you're just starting right and so the
best thing you could do is change up
your your content and try things that
are different to see if you strike a
chord in a different way you know I
think so one thing I had to get over was
I and this will be funny for a lot of
you because a lot of you are newer fans
I am not in love with the motivational
me because I'm scared about motivational
content because so much motivational
content in the world is fluff right it
just it's like it's not good and so I'm
much more proud of my tactical advice
right the video I just made about DMing
like like I like the I like Q&A because
I as you can see I can answer stuff I'm
in it right the rah-rah stuff but I had
to get over the fact that in an
Instagram world those quotes and the
motivational stuff that would be the
Gateway to get you guys in and then the
podcast or we like did daily B is for
you to see how much work it really is
and so you need to try a lot of
different things to see what could
actually be that boosts but the only
thing that's going to work is your
content and patience thank you very much
hey Gary how are you I'm good how are
you
sensational my name is Horia Correa
Haidee Rock can I get some branding
please yeah nice get it I love
I'm watching I'm watching your videos
for a long long time you got a madman
not for years not for years no race guy
so my family has a boutique hotel in in
Transylvania interesting I've been home
for I'm in charge of the marketing for
seven years I've been home for four
years working in the business and I
believe that I got enough expertise too
and I want to put my business online my
personal business online talking about
the things that we learn in the business
and I know you've done it yes
and I'm curious what would be the first
step that you would take to put it
online expertise I would create the home
for the content so you need to decide
there's three ways to communicate the
written word audio and video you need to
decide even just by the way you said hey
d-roc give me the branding like if you
can do video which I think you could you
look suddenly handsome to me you've got
a charisma a are you up for video yeah I
would do this I would do I would do a
YouTube and a facebook video strategy
and I would start putting out content
Instagram as well
one-minute versions on Instagram or if
you want to use carousel long-form on
Facebook and YouTube just start talking
interviewing other experts from the
hotel industry if you want to go that
narrow or other people business experts
from Romania or transmitting if you want
to go that matter if you want to go
macro but my man go look at those first
five or six episodes of Wine Library TV
or askgaryvee or dailyvee it gets better
you get better and better and better and
so don't be precious just start the
first episode should be let me tell you
why I'm here here's my manifesto here's
my thesis I want to tell the world what
I've learned in the trenches over the
last almost decade in my industry in
this interesting place that has other
places in the world similar to it
different than it bla bla bla bla you
know that's what I we do awesome you got
it one more question for you I know that
everywhere you go in the world you make
meetups and this is for everybody here
will you do one in Bucharest so I
promised my wife not to do meetups for a
little while so no okay
all right thanks you're welcome you
could pass it anywhere oh good awesome
how you go hey man I want to ask how
many of you are out there in the world
now just one okay so they're beginning
how many people would you crack a six
hundred billion dollar industry like one
that you pitched yes and when you know
that three companies the United States
actually if I have a market valuation of
nine billion sticking dollars yes and we
are technically technologically more
advanced than them at this point and we
are barely scraping fifty million as of
today so what are you trying to get are
you trying to get venture capital
attention well not really I want to mix
so if you if you check out videos online
videos of products in this particularly
industry
all of them are [ __ ] boring [ __ ]
I want to mix some of that knowledge I
got from you today with a technology
where which not a lot of audience
actually take care or text taken into
consideration so I know mix that somehow
yes still get what the attention of the
big boys and get the modulation basic
videos man I'm telling you so guys how
many people here run Facebook videos
excusing Facebook advertising there's
your hand how many people here are
spending because I know some of you work
for companies that I know for
entrepreneurs this will be harder but
just for context how many people here
are spending twenty five thousand
dollars a month on Facebook Ads raise
your hands so we're spending two three
to three hundred million dollars on
Facebook ads so the advantage we have is
the dollars spent are giving me a lot of
looks my friends there's a weighted
target on Facebook against employees of
a company so a lot of us have put a lot
of data into Facebook so for your
ability to make a video and you got to
keep trying making videos because that's
the magic creative is the variable of
success you can get in front of
everybody in the world if what you say
isn't I got in front of you today
if this keynote sucked I wouldn't have
done anything that's valuable for me
right creative is the variable of
success so you got to make videos but
the fact that you can then take that
video and for $1000 hit the employees of
IBM you know of any venture capital firm
in the world of your competitors of the
people that invested in other 3d
printing companies or pharma companies
Johnson and Johnson
three m GE you can literally take the
video and run them against employees up
those employees then forward that video
to the decision makers within the
organization it is an incredible
opportunity that's what I would do
Thank You Ranch mean how would a company
at that company which are exactly that
geeks with the track attention to one
guy in the world which is you I mean
just email me scary vaynermedia to
corruption I'll be that fifty fifty four
fifty first email I will do father name
personal value oh very nice hi hi
well my tradition Alex I'm cool it may
be stupid but my question is not about
what to do it's about what not to do
okay let me explain sure I'm sure you
have lots of experiences and I guess you
maybe made some mistakes on the road and
you learn from them so please would you
want to share with us a lesson you
learned from a mistake in order for us
to understand and to gain some exciting
what not to do in marketing or in
business or in life in general so thank
you Lexus um
I think first of all let me give you the
best answer to that question which is
the amount of time that I have spent
thinking about my mistakes is all of
them combined
and by the way Alexa I've made a lot is
probably less than one hour okay so the
first thing I would tell you is I am
fascinated by people's ability to dwell
on dumb [ __ ] it already happened I
already [ __ ] up Alexa like like it's
like like of course I'm trying to learn
from it but I would say so my biggest my
biggest consistent flaw is I think I can
do everything got it
so my biggest consistent mistake has
been trying to do too much at once
because I just think I can and and
usually things will fall if you're
trying to balance too many things so the
thing I've learned it's why did
vaynermedia after doing a lot of stuff I
was in Wine Library then I wrote crush
it like rear changed I invested my
career changed and I started doing a lot
of things and I realized wait a minute
like being an operator let me sink my
teeth into one main thing let me have
one main thing that is 80% of me and
then I can play with the other 20% and
that will never crush me because my 80
is going to act like 110 percent and
that lets me play and be an entrepreneur
but I've got my thing so for me that's
the biggest thing I learned and it's
something for everybody you know if
you've got four businesses right now
you've got no businesses right but I
think you know but I do I will tell you
Lex with a better piece of advice I can
give because I think people talk a lot
about learning from their mistakes
unlimited content I want to talk more
about disrespecting your mistakes I
think we overly respect our mistakes I
think we spend way too much time on them
I think we do well on them we worry what
other people think about them and I
think mistakes are much more damaged in
the way we consume it in our own heads
than the mistake in itself and so for me
[ __ ] my mistakes that's great advice
thank you you're welcome
pass it on hi I'm going to go I'm going
to I'm going to mix your passing me up
and I'll mix it up and go deep so you do
a lot of things Gary we and the business
and everything how do you balance Gary
the husband and Gary Vee so work-life
balance is no question the one that
takes the most mine time it all comes
down to communication you know I think
one of the things that I spend a lot of
time on is not being crippled by the
modern politically correct way that you
should be spending time with your family
or spouse so for me as you guys may know
when you come from you know a hardcore
Eastern European work ethic immigrants
background I didn't even see my father
until I was 14 years old and we had the
best relationship and I loved him and I
know you can make it work if that's the
case now I don't assume that that's
going to work for my kids I just know
that that's worked for me my wife her
dad was a very successful corporate
America marketer and he traveled all the
time and she's also comfortable she's an
amazingly independent woman so much so
I'm curious if she still likes me you
know she's you know so she
you know for us it's been very easy it's
called communication we just talk a lot
about how much I work and how much I
travel and for us what's worked as
weekends and vacations right I'm much
more all-in than I was two three years
ago on the weekend and I'm taking seven
weeks vacation instead of two weeks
vacation and in that for now it's
working right my kids are now seven and
four they're getting older I can see
where this is going to break soon and
that's okay by me
but at the same token if I'm not happy
then the whole thing breaks I'm not
trying to live my life based on what you
think I should be doing because I know
politically correct parenting and
husband and wife changes every 10-15
years anyway so I have no interest how
to tell anybody in here had a parent or
how to work in a relationship some of my
best friends you know they have to be
hold live one female founder and she's
talking to me a lot about it because her
husband wants her home so much more
often and I'm like look if you're not
happy it's going to break anyway right
so it's all communication so far so good
you know but I'm not naive to know that
you know my great fear is that my wife
or my child says to me you have to be
home a lot more because for me that's
suffocating you know like I know that
but I have to make decisions and that's
what manifests I would say communication
is the only thing and I'm very pet I'll
tell you I am actually fascinated by the
current modern high-net-worth
politically correct parenting style of
both parents being so deeply involved
because what I'm fascinated by is I see
it very similar to businesses which is
there's no such thing as co-ceos to
cooks in the kitchen is very very
difficult and so I actually think if we
watch this video in 30 or 40 years
there'll be more talk about dividing and
conquering then there is right now and
that's what happens the oven flow so for
me it's just communication and it's just
being there's only four or five people I
have to worry about right my spouse
might
and maybe an in-law or my mom or
something right and so not very
difficult just got to talk about it
often and a business question so you'll
bring content from us to the whole world
how can we go from Romania to the whole
world what's the first step it's harder
one of the great advantages for American
based personalities and businesses is
America the brand is so powerful so
gives us a lot of air cover I think it
comes down to a very similar question
before what's amazing about the world is
if you're the best at what you do
it doesn't matter if you're from the
Amazon River Transylvania or right it
doesn't matter where you're from so the
first thing is the mentality of
understanding that you shouldn't say
well I can't do it because I'm from
Romania you know I hate that mentality
there's such an opportunity especially
when I know there's underpriced
attention in all of Europe and other
places so to me it's a binary switch of
you can do it that's the first one
because every country that isn't America
you know always feels like yeah but we
hear but we hear but yeah but but but
what but but but
so I think if you're if your technology
is that much better it can win Spotify
didn't happen in America right like
there's you know China's doing plenty of
scepters incredible I mean I was doing
real hope there's a real businesses
being built in Romania these are real
businesses in a market size cap that is
not so large so to me it's a mentality
the answer is by doing it yeah give it
to me because I want to set it back I'm
sorry Alec I just want to give some
peeps some chance not guys pretty
athletic too I just didn't want to talk
I don't talk about it often Hey hi Gary
how are you feeling watching you for
seven months so far thank you watch your
name and radda radda for everybody has
it for here about Romania I know if you
guys know but Romania has kind of thirty
percent of the people in NASA we
invented insulin and the jet planes
heady quando so for everybody that
doesn't care doesn't think that we can
accomplish it things here just shut
back up and we have the power and I'm
only 23 okay so my question is actually
because you said that one of the reason
you came shared Romania it's because of
how our the organizer actually
approached you yes I'm just so curious
how they did it how do you make a
worldwide speaker to a Kanto country
like Romania so what what was
interesting was it I listen and it's
funny back to the what like one of the
biggest promises I made to Lizzy a
couple years ago was no I mean this is
my favorite thing to do in the world
like being here with me like this is the
best like I'm looking at the clock in my
clock like I would do this for 11 hours
right like I I love this but one of
things I promise there was no more
traveling unless I actually got the fee
that we agreed on but what they did was
they had a macro plan it wasn't they
started talking about places in the
world that they wanted to scale this to
that I hadn't been to before or were
places in my mind I've been thinking a
lot more in the last three or four years
as you could imagine given where I was
born and my narrative it's been funny
for me of like how I've been thinking
about Eastern Europe because I have so
much permission as an American
entrepreneur that came from this part of
the world to do quite well in these
parts world but only through serendipity
timing like very funny reasons have I
not done a lot of speaking in this part
of the world they also talked about what
they wanted to do in Singapore I've
gotten very aggressive with my content
in Asia and so really it was one just
the general vibe they were very
entrepreneurial I find a lot of like
conferences come at me with more of a
b2b angle and I'm like it feels a little
cold this felt very loosey goosey even
when I got here like that come 30
minutes later I'm like great I was like
a little more you know like it's been
very entrepreneurial but it was very
much also predicated on the two
locations where they wanted to start
this conferences here and the fact that
they wanted to do Singapore so
serendipity to what my strategy was on a
macro content level and the overall
vibes of how they approached it with
like relentlessness and entrepreneurial
spirit versus like going through the
form and just hoping that I would do it
it's really cool awesome
hi I'm Robert from Slovenia hey Robert I
have a small gardening company first
working like on other gardens than like
building a brand and I'm really curious
about one question that is in my mind
like listening to you that is I'm really
young and people don't get the knowledge
from me though they don't believe you
believe me yes yes so my question is if
by priming 16 and trying to sell wine so
my question is if I put a live camera on
my garden I'm a practitioner right and I
have a online business that is covering
it now
really I'm real quick yeah so real quick
I want you hear something if you're
actually a practitioner right of course
show everything you've got because that
will be the punchline so a live
streaming camera
I don't wanna on our webpage no no
notice nobody's gonna go to your [ __ ]
webpage where then I'm on on Facebook
live all the time like every day here
and at first six people gonna watch yeah
and then 7-eleven how many people are
watching you're that person but at
bursts the first one right all I heard
were two numbers you said my first one
had twenty and one of my videos had
250,000 right so like sure listen and
this goes back to you my friend I and
you my friend
if you got it not your age not your
gender not where you're from is going to
stop you if you got it it may be harder
it's harder for a Romanian startup to go
global than a u.s. one yes is it harder
for a female entrepreneur in a man's
world to win absolutely drives me crazy
I invest in so many female entrepreneur
based businesses because it's impossibly
stupid to think that women can't build
the same kind of businesses as men and
they consistently are less expensive to
invest in so I do it not because I'm a
good person because it's a better deal
like I would never think so like I
really really want to squeeze
out and suffocate excuses you're going
to tell everybody's got something you're
gonna tell me you're young great if
you're good enough and you're an actual
practitioner you know what the [ __ ]
you're doing because you've been doing
it your whole life you will win what you
have to do for all of us is you have to
get people to see it
that's why day trading attention is
important because when you don't have
the resources and you don't have the
money or the name or the relationships
the only thing you got is what I had
when I was a kid I was just much smarter
than everybody and I fully committed to
it and I was patient and I worked my
face off the end smarter patient hard
work and was right and just let it
happen that's why I talk about day
trading attention it's the one thing
that we can all win on and that's what
you should do
thank you you're welcome hey before you
throw back yeah go to bath dude I want
to go like further up and make sure
everybody get to the area for now or
we'll get the both of them so can I go a
little late can I go a little bit longer
what's that
got it okay cool all right sorry bro
hi Gary hey first of all my name is mati
I want to thank you I'm an influencer
and you just raised my fee by 20%
they like it it was awesome thank you so
much here huh my question is how do you
go about reinventing your material good
I've been doing this for three years yes
and I start out on vine yes and that
never happened here yeah like Twitter
understand and then went on to east of
Instagram Facebook YouTube but right
after seven seconds video then you do
sketches then you do vlogs and then you
do I do stand-up sometimes but to go
offline but where do you go from there
you know sometimes it's okay for you not
to go anywhere I think it's important
for you to go deep not wide if that's
what the current state of the union is
right for me sometimes people say Gary
you talk about the same stuff or just to
that I'm like yes what I believe in and
it's what I feel inspired to talk about
right now so I much like I said over
here you may want to challenge yourself
into new settings you know how I did you
see that thing where I said document
versus creating yeah so maybe one thing
you may want to do is change the content
into you being you the human and you
documenting the journey to find you
creative you see where I'm going I know
it's kind of something I'm doing right
now because I've been creating
characters like I've never really talked
about myself yeah so now yes so I feel
like that's kind of what I'm trying to
do and it's kind of scary because I'm
letting people in yeah how do you go
about that like not for me I've been
comfortable letting people in but not
all the way so for another thing about
family one thing that a lot of people
realize is I don't share any content of
my family like I'm always out and about
everything I mean hard to find any
pictures of my children at all so I
don't want to force you to let people in
I think it's a huge pillar it's an
opportunity but if it's not something
you're comfortable with you shouldn't
have to do it but I go about it because
I'm very comfortable because I'm I love
it I want people in but this doesn't
come natural to everybody and so you
should let it go at the pace that you're
most comfortable with I'll have to see
something like most success I've had was
by doing stuff that I'm very
uncomfortable about go figure so yeah so
I'll have to find that balance
thanks so much you got it my man hi Gary
149 147 good good
I took question yeah first my name is
Cornell when can we take a picture
together right now right now yeah okay I
will come okay
second it's kind of a follow up you said
about documenting the journey yes where
do you draw the line what you must not
document I think everybody's different I
should come down I decided not to talk
about my family because that's my line
most people are successful who are
bloggers using their family kids and
relationships and pets they do very well
on media I don't use any of those things
so my man I think it's different for
everybody right like I don't go into
everything about my family dynamics you
know I keep a lot of stuff that's
between me and AJ and me and my dad you
know to myself connects to following me
too so I think I think again it's a very
personal thing
it's a it's a very personal thing I feel
like we're wrapping up here let me say
this sorry this is this is a very
personal thing and it starts with
self-awareness don't do what I've done
don't do what other people done start
trying to figure yourself out put your
toe into things try things but please if
anything please progress please please
promise me one thing
please understand we are in it right now
I can come back here in three years and
be like you [ __ ] up Facebook's now
properly priced it's $35 CPMs not six
Google is tired and mature Facebook's
now mature and nothing has popped up
from 2011 12 13 there was nothing great
like Facebook was happening like until
the ad proud like we are in it right now
please take advantage of it thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen put your
hands together for Gary Vaynerchuk thank
you bro thank you so much now you know
why he's the hottest speaker in the
world right thank you